Five four,
three,
two law and with luck due
a bright to the dark side.
Now you playing quick. I
got my ass whooped. Yeah.
Well you were in a fucking melee. There's
three other dudes and they're blasting.
It's a one on one map that maps chaos.
This is so fun though.
How Fun is that Shit? It reminds me of
golden eye. Do you ever get into that?
How dare you? First of all,
64 that's a great game.
That came can suck all the dicks.
You using those stupid x-box things
lets you control a mouse and keyboard.
It's where you're at.
That's why you get fucked up.
You don't even know how to move.
It was hard for me to move back and forth.
If it was the controller game on
what? Yeah, cause nobody can move.
Nobody can move. Then you're all
right with control this and did that.
Fucking that games chaos.
Jamie and I've been going back and
forth for fucking four or five days now.
You'd be surprised. There are a
couple of guys that can compete.
A few that can compete with the mouse
and keyboard. I wouldn't be surprised.
I'm sure that Ken,
but they have zero life and they don't
even know what a pussy looks like.
The quickest quakes old score, right?
Yeah. Cool. We're on quick for,
but this quake champions that you play
online. We've been playing quake for,
because we could set it up on what's
called a local area network, a lan,
and it's real easy and there's no latency.
It's just direct from
computer to computer.
It's fun to this thing
on the one guy he there.
He's really aggressive workout dude.
What's that? The guy that I'm thinking of,
he's a, he's a video video can
play a very good, he's really good.
He hasn't named Nick Marks. I'm
only, I'm sure he gets pussy.
There's some good looking dude. Yeah,
I'm sure there are. I'm sure there are,
but it's not fun to say no. It's fun
to say that they weighed four pounds.
You'd like to picture Miss Jazz.
Yeah, they can't find their deck,
but now those kids and get hot shit.
There's even hot chicks who
play video games. Oh yeah.
Well it's a good move for hot chick.
Like there's,
there's hot chicks than hunt because
like in they wear makeup and shit,
full eyelashes and shed because
it brings them into that world.
And then all the guys were hooligan
hers. She loves what? Oh look.
Yeah.
It was like stand in front of like
endangered species with their tits out.
Like there's hot girls to
take Moitai class. Right.
And they get all serious angry face.
Don't talk to anybody.
Pretend they're real fighters. Some of
them are real, some of them are not.
Though. Some of them get super serious.
That's when I whisper like this. Yeah.
When they say, I don't like when people
say, I'm going, I'm going to train today.
I'm like, well what are you doing?
He'd taken [inaudible] training.
That's not training.
We trained for what we'll do training
for the talk lips to be training for some
deck.
His God damn games,
they're so addictive.
You word like straight up
addicted to them, right? Oh
yeah. I had a real problem.
Well, I kind of got a
little bit of a problem now.
Jamie and I have been talking back and
forth. He's up on me a little bit too.
That's why I have to kick Jeff out every
now and then just with Jamie and I go
one on one.
One last time I fucked him up and he hit,
he quit cause me and Jeff are easy prey,
right?
Like you can just not easy prey anymore.
Jeff was easy prey for a little bit.
If I want all these games, how long do you
think we'd be here playing quake? True.
You want to get you one.
All these keys to competitive,
you wouldn't say and you lost 13 to
five because you were trying real hard.
You got fucked up son.
I let you up and talking change.
You were talking shit and he
says, yeah, sure. Fucked him up.
The problem with having another person
in in the thing is he always goes after
Jeff first. He said, easy kill.
That's what he comes and gets me.
I can barely get my fucking be quiet.
Yes, are killing me right away.